[Musica]
[Risate]
splendido
buon pomeriggio prima di tutto grazie di
essere stati fino adesso è stata una
giornata fantastica e spero di finirla
[Musica]
nello stesso spirito
parliamo di donne in orbita perché a
questo punto facciamo il countdown che
abbiamo già visto uno prima del lancio
azione uno shuttle quindi un lancio nasa
il primo countdown per portare un uomo
dello spazio è stato il russo yuri
gagarin lo vedete aprile 1961 tenente
della dell'armata rossa
diciamo così un aviatore vedete che ha
sulla sull'elmetto la scritta unione
delle repubbliche socialiste sovietiche
quindi più chiaro di così non si può
essere il primo uomo nello spazio un
grandissimo successo per
ricordatevi che l'unione sovietica era
stata anche la prima nazione al mondo a
mettere in orbita un satellite
artificiale il famoso studi e un
grandissimo schiaffo agli stati uniti
guardate questo è uno delle centinaia di
me pagine di giornali americani
allora c'erano ovviamente molti più
giornali di quanti non ce ne siano oggi
io ho scelto di farmi vedere lo il times
huntsville è un posto in a l'avana dove
c'era e c'è ancora
ovviamente un centro di ricerca della
casa nel centro di ricerca dove von
braun stava sviluppando i cacciatori per
gli astronauti americani
guardate questo giornale l'uomo entra
nello spazio
guardate sotto alla vostra sinistra dice
dicono volevamo essere noi primi ma
eravamo così dc in fondo a destra cioè
tagliato von braun e dice a questo punto
dobbiamo correre come detti sperti il
americani avevano un loro programma
spaziale non è che si fossero fatti
prendere totalmente alla sprovvista e
già nel 59 avevano selezionato la loro
prima classe di astronauti 7 si chiamano
mercury serve perché avrebbero volato
sulle navicelle mercury che hanno il
primo passo prima mercury poi gelimini
poi apollo per andare sulla luna
quindi ragazzi dobbiamo correre sperati
per rassicurare l'opinione pubblica
americana che dice ma insomma noi
combattere remussi anzi dai sovietici e
e quindi meno di un mese dopo
lanciano il primo astronauta a lance fa
però non sono pronti e quindi non
possono lanciare in orbita devono fare
un volo suborbitale tipo quello che farà
fare ai riccastri che vogliono dare a
vomitare nello spazio pagando 250 mila
euro
contenti loro contenti tutti comunque il
primo vero astronauta americano è john
glenn l'anno dopo ci vuole un po di
tempo per prepararsi e john gray
effettivamente orbita intorno alla terra
il programma americano è come si dice in
full swing c'è
il presidente kennedy è molto entusiasta
della cosa farà il famoso discorso
dell'unione eccetera ma e quindi
selezionano la nuova classe di
astronauti questi si chiama new line
perché sono altri nove per esempio
vedete che il nostro grazie
il secondo di quelli appoggiati sulla
destra il diciamo gli americani sono
pensano di essere veramente e
spiegazione pronti a battere i sovietici
ma ci danno un'altra di quelli schiaffi
terrificanti
la prima donna nello spazio 1963 giugno
valentina tereskova anche lei alle
trincee
anche lei ovviamente era un militare e a
differenza degli stati uniti di unione
sovietica
l'armata russa permetteva l'accesso alle
donne che potevano essere ufficiali
quindi a questo punto uno si chiede gli
americani sono stati schiaffeggiati alla
grande da yuri gagarin cosa faranno
adesso che sono stati schiaffeggiati
alla grande un'altra volta lo fa e
golosamente niente dicono ask una donna
propaganda solistica e continuano come
se nulla fosse successo
continuano a selezionare i loro stronati
continuano a selezionarli tutti i
maschietti
questo è un insieme di tutti gli
astronauti della missione apollo quella
che ci ha portato sulla luna tutti
quelli vestiti di bianco con la tuta di
volo sono le astronavi di claudio volato
ed hanno portato a te
missione quelli ingrate trovata sono
quelli di apollo 13 che hanno portato a
casa la pelle che già tanto
quando succede un disastro come quello
di apollo 13 gli è esploso osservatorio
di ossigeno quindi una situazione
estremamente difficile
quelli con la tuta azzurra sono gli
astronauti di apollo che sono morti a
terra durante una sessione di training
diciamo così c'è stato un terribile
incendio nella capsula dove loro erano
sigillati e fatto in tempo ad aprire e
loro sono morti
il quindi uomini in orbita però poco
mondo anche uguali mia terra
perché vedete questa è la sala il
controllo quella di huston dovessi la
gente
salta di gioia perché apollo 11 è
tornato a casa sono hanno fatto uno
splash down nell'oceano sono stati
ripescati avevano 50 per cento di
probabilità di uscire è quindi la casa
che gli stati uniti avevano preso delle
e dei rischi a testi che adesso nessuno
avrebbe il coraggio di prendere quindi
momento di grande gioia trovate qualcuno
sa che non abbia una tra batta sono
tutti buoni e allo stesso modo questo è
un altra bisogno di un'altra sala di
controllo un momento molto teso huston
cui è vero e proprio quando per gli
astronauti hanno detto siamo nel filo e
qui sono tutti estremamente preoccupati
perché si stanno chiedendo come portarli
a casa
quindi non c'erano donne interessate
allo spazio
poniamoci questa questo quesito
fondamenta il 50 per cento della
popolazione femminile se ne fregava
totalmente nello spazio
la risposta è assolutamente sbagliato le
donne c'erano ma la nasa non le ha mai
considero questo per diversi motivi
prima di tutto perché tutti i primi tre
classi che ha suonato nella casa erano
piloti collaudatori quindi erano persone
che siano formate tutti nei ranghi
militari venivano tutti dalla guerra di
corea fondamentalmente erano variazione
nei di marines tutto quello che volete
voi ma attività e a quell'epoca
gli stati uniti non permettevano
l'ingresso delle donne quindi però
c'erano donne alle attrici per esempio
che avrebbero potuto tranquillamente
fare lo stesso lavoro non erano piloti
collaudatori militari ma erano di
attrici professioniste e la storia
raccontata in un libro mercuri 13 che è
anche tradotto in italiano che racconta
la storia di 13 aviatrici che hanno
superato tutti i test fisici che
venivano fatti superano che dovevano
essere superati dai disastri in auto
e quindi è stato il medico degli
astronauti che ha chiamato queste donne
abbia trici perché era curioso di vedere
come le donne avrebbero reagito ai test
e che lui faceva fare gli astronauti
quando le donne hanno superato i test
lui ha chiesto il permesso di andare
avanti alla casa che a casa ha detto e
strano questo la risposta purtroppo è no
non è strano
ricordatevi che il mese scorso è venuto
fuori che da dieci anni una grande
università del giappone trucca i
risultati degli esami di ammissione alla
facoltà di cucina per limitare
donne questa è ovviamente uno scandalo
notevolissimo ma uno scandalo è stato
accettabile oltre dieci anni da tutti
della facoltà
quindi è un qualcosa di profondamente
collegato alla cultura perché qualcuno
decide che aprirà del medico ospedaliero
non è adatta alle donne
qualcuno che ovviamente non è una nonna
ma comunque torniamo alla storia di cui
13 perché è interessante
una di queste tredici signore la seconda
a destra in alto
james era moglie di un senatore
democratico che è quindi il senatore ha
aiutato queste signore ad avere una
udienza congresso degli stati uniti
perché il signore hanno denunciato la
discriminazione di genere fatta dalla
nasa
il congresso di gioco del signore
riescono a
incontrare il vice presidente lyndon
johnson che era il in aveva la
responsabilità della dei progetti
spaziali e vedete in questa immagine che
gioco si dice non se ne fa niente non
vogliamo mettere le tendine alle nostre
sonde spaziali
quindi è una storia a diciamo di
discriminazioni di genere che
del suo 6 o guardi
[Musica]
quindi se cercate su netflix mercury 13
provate questo documentario
quindi il cinema è un modo potente di
riportare in vita di riportare a memoria
di quello che è successo e per esempio
vi ricordo anche la storia di catherine
johnson e sue colleghe matematiche di
colore che lavoravano alla nasa
lavoravano sempre dietro le quinte non
ne faccio
e anche entrare nella sala di controllo
importavano i foglietti per fare i conti
fuori che è stata raccontata nel bel
film ha il diritto di contare che in
inglese si chiama il 20 go cioè i
personaggi nascosti ma veniamo ai giorni
nostri
vediamo la storia continua e nel 1983
vent'anni dopo valentina tereskova gli
stati uniti lasciando la prima
astronauta sandy ride e farà nel 1995
parte lo choc con la prima comandante
donna leinì collins che invita le
signore di m i 13 quelle che erano
ancora in vita e avuto piacere di andare
a vedere il lancio perché dice
pubblicamente è grazie agli sforzi che
questi signori hanno fatto che io sono
arrivata dove sono arrivata lei castro
date oggi non sono più una rarità
tuttavia sono
ignoranza nel senso che qui vedete
samantha cristoforetti che si fa
camminando al centro degli astronauti
russo vicino ad uno scala città nelle
stelle e in tutto contando tutte gli
astronauti che sono andati nello spazio
dell'intero romano i giorni nostri
le donne sono circa il 10 per cento del
totale
aumentera questa percentuale alcuni
segni positivi ci sono
questa è la flotta dei nove astronauti
della nasa che prenderanno parte ai voli
commerciali cioè ai voli che avranno
luogo sul micelle costruite da spaces o
da altre ditte che fanno questo questo
lavoro appunto dal punto di vista
commerciale vedete che su nove
astronauti due sono donne e 1 e nero wow
stiamo già perché anche in fase precoce
sono una grande rilevanza ma ci sono
anche
un pochino meno grandi ma sempre
estremamente importanti se i film ci
dicono qualcosa sul sentimento popolare
diciamo così questa è la squadra degli
astronauti che è la protagonista del
film il sopravvissuto mar
matt damon più sfigato di tutti è quello
in alto a destra ma vedete che la
dell'equipaggio è fatto da sei
astronauti 2 e in quella in alto a
sinistra è la comandante sarà lei che
deciderà la musica mento e quando la
nasa dice tu adesso torni a casa che
dice no io torno a matite per andare a
riprenderlo mettendo ovviamente a
repentaglio la vita sua
tutti gli altri che erano tutti
d'accordo per altro perché se no
marzia mo sarebbe morto per mancanza di
sostentamento perfetto se uno adesso noi
stiamo pensando di colonizzare marte
scendiamo che elon musk vuole portare
che il presidente degli stati uniti
vorrebbero che si arrivasse a marte dopo
2034 eccetera
se vogliamo fare una colonia sull'arte
signori le donne diventano necessità
biologica perché ovviamente se vogliamo
fare dei marziani
ci vogliono delle marziane che quindi se
se vogliamo fare una colonia su un su un
altro pianeta
largo alle donne astronauti bisogna dire
che c'è anche gente che si fingeva di
immaginazione degli astrofisici
specialmente quando si mettono insieme
ai filosofi e sociologi
così diventa infinita e è uscito un
lavoro devo dire una stanza
interessante un lavoro più di sociologia
che di astrofisica che parla chi cerca
di fare il conto della più piccola
diciamo equipaggio che uno potrebbe
pensare di mettere a bordo di una nave
spaziale per permettere un viaggio di
molti migliaia di anni per arrivare alla
stella più vicina
proxima centauri è la più vicina è a 4,2
anni luce la luce cr 4,2 anni una nave
spaziale pur andando a una velocità
sostenuta chi metterebbe diverse
migliaia di anni quindi i diversi di aia
di anni noi dobbiamo avere l'isola
felice dove le generazioni si susseguono
e ovviamente sono in grado di auto
sostenersi senza pensare ai problemi di
autosostentamento che non sono banali
questi hanno fatto solo un lavoro di
vedere qual è il numero minimo di
persone che possano garantire la
sopravvivenza della specie per un tempo
disegni la e signori e signori non
sarete
sempre fatti di sapere e ci vogliono
metà uomini e metà donne ei suoi
indirizzi
[Musica]
è partito il countdown per la parità
grazie
[Musica]
a milano